30 minute workouts
20 minute recipes 10 minute mindfulness
ready to become
[Music]
get filled on the app store or google
play morning guys i hope you had a good
sleep and i hope you're feeling
refreshed right now so before you jump
out of bed i want you to join me and do
this ab exercises right on your bed
do this regularly for a stronger core
and also a tighter mid section
only seven exercises okay so let's start
by lying in bed
so we want to start off really easy lie
in bed okay make sure you find your
comfortable spot all i want you to do is
reach your arms up
alternating between your left knee to
your chest okay ready
let's go i'm straight
alternating hug your knee
bring your knee close to your chest
and let's
start to activate the core muscles
and lengthen
your spine good
so it's also about stretching yourself
wicking your muscles up good so
knee to your chest
alternating between left and right
very good
as you come up
breathe out okay
keep going
last two more
last one more
and good
a short 20 second rest for the second
exercise i want you to grab your pillow
it's going to be full extension okay so
same movement but this time with your
pillow and activating your core even
more we want to crunch up
all right place the pillow on your feet
extend out
crunch up again grab it
both legs together extend
good
so this is a really good workout for
your upper
as well as your lower abs so
balance yourself up okay
do not drop the pillow extend straight
go as low as you can
stretch out
and up
keep going
nice
last few more final balance point your
toes
last one more
point your toes
extend and grab the pillow very good
okay for the third exercise we're still
using our pillow okay so it's going to
be scissors what i'm going to do is grab
your pillow all right
place your pillow just right above your
chest and i want you to start to
scissors your leg left
and right
left and right okay
so the whole point of having the pillow
is as an indicator for you to reach your
legs towards the pillow
and this workout is going to activate
your lower abs even more
you're going to start to feel the burn
good point your toes
very good left and right do not rush
through the workout keep your legs
straight
last 15 seconds crunch up
lift your shoulders
off the bed
last few more point
point
and slowly
come
back
up okay
time to push yourself up okay
and this time the next workout is going
to be russian twist i want you to sit
firmly on your butt okay
again grabbing hold of a pillow
legs up
all i want to do is
twist your torso
left and right okay that's it
so
it's not a fast movement
it's not a vigorous movement
but
this isometric movement will really work
on your core and your obliques
so remember kills off the bed if you can
if this is too tough then you can rest
your heels
on your bed
and twisting from left to right
again with the pillow
good extend your arms
left and right
left and right
can you feel your car burning
that's good morning
last one more
and just shake it out okay now
put your pillow aside
the next is going to be a crisscross
reverse plank so choose your option you
can either lay down onto your bed or
support your upper body
with your arms alright so we want to get
into a crisscross
and slowly bring your leg straight up
and slowly bring it back down
close to the bed
and again small movement
nice
and controlled
good up
remember to breathe
very good down
if your bed is slightly on the soft side
you will find that you might be sinking
in okay
engage your core
last few more down
and up
and just come up
okay
now
a little bit
of a challenge on your balance okay it's
going to be a reverse
plank with crunch okay so on your butt
on your palms
lift yourself up okay
so start on your left leg all the way to
do extend your left leg crunch it in
bring it out crunch it in and bring it
out okay so
final balance find
your
core strength
and keeping your body
straight do not dip your hip extend kick
it out extend and kick it out okay left
leg down right leg up
crunch
extend crunch so it's just like the
first movement
knee to chest but this time
we're upping up
the intensity
to engage your core even more up
knee to chest crunch
crunch
and crunch
all right guess what this is your final
workout it's going to be a roll up it's
time to get out of bed okay
so lie
on your bed
extend your arms i want you to
use your core strength to roll yourself
back up hug your knee
extend and roll yourself up okay good
hold it for two counts right at the top
extend
and come up
nice
crunch up
and release
up hold it
and slowly lower yourself
up
[Music]
all right
very very
well done that was a seven minute ab
workout
right on your bed again do this workout
regularly for a stronger car and also a
tighter mid section
if you want to you can even do this
workout on your mat
and if you do enjoy this workout be sure
to give this video a thumbs up
share it on and don't forget to also
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more home workouts healthy recipes
and also full meal plan and i will see
you next time
all the best
have an amazing day ahead